♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THIS IS A MAN CALLED ANDREW
CUOMO.
MR. CUOMO IS THE GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
NEW YORK IS ONE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT PLACES IN THE
ENGLISH-SPEAKING WORLD.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE QUALITIES
YOU NEED TO POSSESS IN ORDER TO
RUN A PLACE LIKE THAT.
ANDREW CUOMO HAS THOSE QUALITIES
AND HE FIGURES HE CAN RIDE THEM
ALL THE WAY TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
INSTEAD, UNDER THE NEW YORKER
BECAME PRESIDENT FOR THIS AND
RANGED ANDREW CUOMO.
HE'S BEEN MAD EVER SINCE.
>> THE FIRST YEAR, WE LOST
40,000 PEOPLE TO GUN DEATHS.
THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN 50 YEARS.
NEW YORK WILL MOVE FORWARD!
NOT BY BUILDING A WALL'S, MY
FRIENDS!
BUT BY BUILDING NEW BRIDGES!
THE UNIFIER FOR THE DEMOCRATS IS
THEIR ANGER AND FEAR AT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO TRULY HATE DONALD TRUMP,
ANDREW CUOMO TUMBLED HEADLONG
INTO THE RABID LINE OF RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY.
IN HIS DEFENSE, IT MADE KIND OF
SENSE.
TRUMP IS BAD IN ORANGE,
THEREFORE HE'S A TRADER WHO
WORKS FOR PUTIN.
CUOMO MADE THAT POINT ON
TWITTER, "TRUMP IS AIDING AND
ABETTING PUTIN, COVERING UP
RUSSIA'S INFLUENCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS."
AIDING AND ABETTING, A COVER UP!
CALL THE POLICE, THE RUSSIANS
ARE HERE!
CUOMO APPEARED TO BELIEVE ALL OF
THIS AND MANY PEOPLE DID.
IMAGINE HOW THOSE PEOPLE MUST'VE
FELT YESTERDAY.
FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS, THEY
WAITED FOR THEIR GOD TO DELIVER
THEM FROM THEIR ORANGE GOD.
IT WAS ALL A HOAX.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
ANDREW CUOMO AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIKE ANDREW CUOMO SUDDENLY
LOOKED PRETTY STUPID.
LUCKILY, ANDREW CUOMO AND THOSE
PEOPLE.
NEW YORK IS LIKE THAT.
HIS LITTLE BROTHER WORKS AT CNN.
THAT'S NOT REALLY SURPRISING,
LOTS OF PEOPLE ON SCENE AND HAS
CLOSE TIES TO THE PARTY,
INCLUDING THE GUY WHO RUNS THE
PLACE, JEFF ZUCKER.
HE SAYS HE MAY RUN HIMSELF,
THINKING JUST TO FLIP ON CNN.
LAST NIGHT, PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
ON CNN, THE OLDER BROTHER LOOKED
ESPECIALLY AGITATED.
PEOPLE CRITICIZING CNN, DOESN'T
LIKE THAT.
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LET PEOPLE
SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, CNN, THE
MEDIA OR WHATEVER, THEY'VE BEEN
CREATING A FALSE NARRATIVE.
THIS REPORT IS PLENTY OF PROOF
THAT THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ASKED REPEATEDLY WHERE
LEGIT AND THAT THE ANSWERS WE
WERE GETTING CONSISTENTLY WERE
NOT, ESPECIALLY ONCE YOU GET
PAST THE LINE OF, HEY, ARE YOU A
FELON?
ONCE YOU MOVE PAST THAT, THE
THINGS THEY DID COMMIT MEETINGS
THEY HAVE HAD TO, THE
EXPLANATIONS THEY GAVE, THE
WRONG CONSISTENTLY.
>> Tucker: DID YOU GET THAT?
I'M NOT GOING TO LET PEOPLE -- I
WON'T ALLOW THAT!
TO WHICH YOU MIGHT,
UNDERSTANDABLY RESPOND, WHO
CARES WHAT YOU THINK, PAL.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE THE
GOVERNOR'S LITTLE BROTHER GETS
TO MEAN THAT YOU GET TO TELL ME
THAT BUZZ OFF.
OKAY, YOU COULD SAY THAT.
YOU COULD IGNORE HIS ORDERS
ENTIRELY.
THAT'S UP TO YOU.
BUT BEFORE YOU MAKE ANY HASTY
DECISIONS, WE THOUGHT YOU OUGHT
TO SEE THIS.
>> YOU GUYS WHO ARE ASKING FOR
THE FITNESS TEST?
I WILL GIVE YOU ONE.
THEY KEY TO THIS IS MAKE SURE
THAT THE DUMBBELLS MAKE YOUR
BODIES LIKE THIS GO UP AND DOWN.
DO YOU SEE ME COMING LIKE THAT?
YOU AREN'T EXERCISING RIGHT.
>> Tucker: WOAH.
ASK YOURSELF AGAIN, DO YOU
REALLY WANT TO CRITICIZE CNN?
DOES THAT SEEM LIKE A SMART
MOVE?
THIS IS NEW YORK.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S LITTLE
BROTHER SUGGEST YOU SHOULD DO OF
SOMETHING, YOU SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION IF YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOOD FOR YOU.
REPEAT AFTER ME, CNN WAS NEVER
WRONG.
CNN GOT IT RIGHT.
CNN IS THE MOST TRUSTED NAME IN
NEWS.
GOOD.
THE GOVERNOR'S BROTHER LIKES IT
BETTER WHEN YOU TALK THAT WAY.
IF ONLY EVERYONE WAS SO
OBEDIENT.
LET'S BE HONEST, NOT EVERYBODY
IS THAT OBEDIENCE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO POINT
OUT THAT CNN DID, STRICTLY
SPEAKING, GET THE BIGGEST STORY
OF THE DECADE COMPLETELY AND
UTTERLY, AND FLAMBOYANTLY WRONG.
PEOPLE WILL SAY THAT NO MATTER
HOW MANY BARBELLS IT'S ANCHORS
LIFT.
BECAUSE IT'S UNDENIABLY TRUE.
IT WASN'T JUST TO SEE AND THEN.
VIRTUALLY THE ENTIRE NEWS MEDIA
DID THE SAME THING.
THIS WAS A FAILURE ON AN
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE.
THE RUSSIA HOAX WASN'T PART OF
WHAT THE MEDIA COVERED.
IT WAS ALL THEY COVERED FOR
YEARS.
THE NUMBERS ARE REMARKABLE.
OVER THE FIRST 60 DAYS OF 2018,
JUST TO PICK IT ALMOST AT
RANDOM, THE EVENING NEWS SHOWS
ON THE BROADCAST NETWORKS SPENT
TWICE AS MUCH TIME TALKING ABOUT
THE RUSSIA HOAX AS ANY OTHER
TOPIC.
PRINT, EVEN MORE PROFOUND.
SINCE THE 2016 ELECTION, GIVING
YOU ONE MEASURE, MORE THAN
150,000 AMERICANS HAVE DIED FROM
DRUG OVERDOSE.
THAT IS FAR MORE THAN THE NUMBER
OF AMERICANS KILLED DURING THE
ENTIRE SECOND WORLD WAR IN THE
PACIFIC.
GUATEMALA CANAL, OKINAWA,
IWO JIMA, THOSE BATTLES TOOK
MORE THEY'LL MAKE YOUR
LIVES OVER A SHORTER PERIOD.
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          N
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          W
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          Y
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          R
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          ,
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          N
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          W
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          Y
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          R
SOMEHOW, THE NEW YORK          ,
TIMES TOOK NO NOTICE OF IT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE TWICE
AS MANY STORIES ABOUT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THAT MATTERED MORE TO THEM.
"THE WASHINGTON POST," THE RATIO
IS EVEN STARKER.
LAST YEAR, JEFF BEZOS' NEWSPAPER
RAN 4,319 ARTICLES ABOUT THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
IT RAN A LITTLE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND TO MENTION THE OPIOID
CRISIS.
AMERICA'S SHRINKING MIDDLE
CLASS?
THAT GOT A TOTAL OF 119 MENTION
MENTIONS.
THEY JUST DIDN'T CARE.
THEY WEREN'T PRETENDING
OTHERWISE.
THEY DON'T CARE.
CABLE NEWS WAS, AS YOU KNOW,
EVEN WORSE.
ALL RUSSIA, ALL THE TIME.
FOR YEARS, TO THE EXCLUSION OF
EVERYTHING ELSE, INCLUDING,
OBVIOUSLY THE TRUTH.
RELENTLESS, REPETITIVE,
CALCULATING THE DISHONEST.
THE VERY DEFINITION OF
PROPAGANDA.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
THEY CAN'T STOP.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT TOO LONG
FOR IT WATCH THEM TEST DRIVE THE
NEW TALKING POINT.
SEE IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY WHICH
WORD THE DNC HAS TOLD THEM TO
USE.
>> THE REPORT HAS A POTENTIALLY
LIST OF WAYS THE PRESIDENT TRY
TO "INFLUENCE" THE INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
>> IT IS AN UGLY DAMNING PIECE
OF BUSINESS.
>> I AGREE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
DAMNING.
>> FAR MORE THAN THE PRESIDENT
INITIALLY INDICATED.
>> BUT IT'S STILL VERY DAMNING.